hello and welcome to this video playing
I am Sherlock with white theatre
interesting line is played at against me
some earlier games interesting so that
six stops stops any a five but on the
other hand black basically says I'm that
here doesn't mind to play age 65 if need
be well Pena is extremely annoying so
let's see can I have somehow use the use
the pin better from Queen 21 would force
upon move but it's rather slow maybe
this one maybe d5 pawn takes 25
the id-5 was good okay now night is fawn
come on it's really dangerous right I
mean I know what is he porn but what's
what about your king can take that first
and then see Knight takes pawn takes
Bishop h6 is one thing the other would
be to take and check them yeah I think
it's dangerous very dangerous actually
okay now f5 Knight f6 is just
immediately over I think you have to
play monkey ate more or less to have
rook g7 as a possible defense yeah so
I'm taking it think when you kiss and
now I just need another look an
additional look here on the third rank
look the 1d three this kind of thing so
not easy if you'd like to get this
somehow coordinated then yes no way to
take the night and now the look is stuck
with the defense of h7 so I just play
hoopty 3h three and made them on h7 is
the plan
no good well the moment I don't see a
defense to be honest the combination of
night and Queenie as extremely extremely
strong yeah so I go here look see three
maybe no
never now go on the third you have some
yes Lucas III inside to count a plane
hope this real group takes c3 the night
might even come to the five Wow come on
they don't tell me that this is
defensible for black there will be
absolutely weird there's some other way
to play be fired maybe some something
something with that
fifty-three Knight c3
I don't fear when absolutely great I
absolutely don't see a little shine
learning amazing amazing
and what trade does 95 I mean tweets
Evelyn and teacher censored because of
Quincy one made something weird name now
I know it blocks the third that means
got check and clean g5 anyway ohs great
okay well that that's a really
frustrating game and I that looks in
totally unplayable I mean like totally
and it's totally lost to us the engine
confirms but again i'm an idiot i cannot
win the simplest wins and i am queen
a380 resizer just two candidate move you
know i mean it cannot work yeah he's
getting into this absolutely deadly pin
which is totally apparent that cannot
work but there's just one way queen a
three and this doesn't work which is
crazy that this is the distant winning
or it is winning rookie four wins with
look G fall game but this doesn't draw
this is not enough yeah crazy that's
crazy I had also win because I can
employ a look-see one and the distance
is not enough right I said silouan I
mean
[Applause]
okay solid i hook the hook d to e three
wow that feels computers I don't even
understand it when I I know that my move
lost but I didn't see anything that
would work so okay it's kind of crazy to
look for moves here because the game
should have been over for a long time
already and I just didn't do it just
didn't do it so this even would have won
I mean it's it's made them just made but
the idea is the screen f3 this is
disaster the easiest one and just over
on f6 the gun you need to calculate any
line now gmta you can also find wins
look in for 4g 4s also very good yeah
you know I was thinking this wins very
conveniently and it doesn't it is not
easy I mean this all of a sudden dusted
him because he has Luke takes c3 after i
go here yeah this is the problem and he
threatening made himself made them yet
anyway thanks so much